I'm curious about you know
in this movie we go to the quantum realm
and we see the variants pop up of you
and of Paul's character if you could
spend time
with your variants what would that be
like for you is that something that you
would want to do go to dinner go to
lunch or are you kind of best maybe on
your own
I feel like I'll I spend a lot of time
with my variants that is how I live my
life I'm constantly putting on different
elements of myself and taking them for
test drives and seeing how they feel I
feel like if you Google me you and just
look at images you'd be like that's 700
different women she's never the same
person and then I'm also an actress by
trade so even there I get to once again
to put on different elements of myself
and see how they feel so I feel like I'm
I'm very intimate with my variants in
real life
what would the teenage years say about
the fact that you are now several movies
in with Michelle Pfeiffer and Mr Douglas
ugh
I don't think she would believe me I I
really don't first of all she didn't
have any aspirations to be an actress
but
Michelle Pfeiffer was an idol when I was
young for me Catwoman was the fantasy I
wanted to be Catwoman and I thought she
was perfect I truly thought there was no
more perfect woman in the world than
Michelle Pfeiffer and I still pinched
myself when you know she shoots me a
text and her name comes up on my phone
and I just think what is going on in my
life that this is my friend
that's wild just amazing to be like do
you if someone's with you are you like
look look who it is look at this no I
try to be cool she is actually my friend
that's great
um you know we're seeing a real uh sort
of Changing of the Guard now in Phase
five
um the introduction of these new
superheroes what's your advice if you
have any for younger actors coming in to
the MCU and taking on these roles and
these responsibilities
um
gosh that's a good question
um I the I called Catherine Newton cat
who plays Cassie Lang in Quantum Mania
she plays um the grown-up Cassie Lang
when I found out that she would have
been cast for the role
and we had a little talk I just you know
let her know that I was there for her
and then I had her back and anything she
needed I was I was her woman and she was
so sweet and so humble and she asked me
do you have any advice for me
and I just told her just be prepared to
focus very hard these roles in some ways
are very light lifting in the acting
Department because it's not high drama
and there's a lot of technicality to it
but that technicality requires an
incredible amount of focus and I don't
think I could have prepared myself or
predicted how much focus is required to
work on a green screen in a constant
basis hold an entire world in your
imagination remember the mechanics of
what is moving in that world and where
it is and what you're supposed to be
looking at and then remember where
you're supposed to put your body because
with the CGI things can be very very
technical of like when and where and how
you move
and still somehow remain present
emotionally and perform so it requires
an immense amount of focus which I think
a lot of people don't realize coming
into it